I there's been way too many cases. Obviously our people are going,
we're going broke spending.
How many cases do you know, how many do you know here at all time, from who,
from who.
You asked, how many people had like spent a significant amount of their savings,
or like, I spent too much money. Oops, sorry.
Spent an amount of money that ended up like they regretted.
I bet there would be like 50% minimum.
No, we can do it right now. We can do it. I'm fine.
I don't Twitter. Have you ever spent in a month.
Amount of money on a Gacha game or video game that you ended up severely
regressing, be honest, be honest, be totally honest with a proper scientist.
The conduct we're doing right now. We actually want to know no me.
I'm actually genuinely curious. I love gaming. So I am a gamer gamers,
rise up, rise and grind.
Hi, I am a casual gamer. I just like enjoying my time playing a video game.
And if I, you know, if,
if I wanted to enjoy my time pulling for some wild foods, then that I know,
I know that that's on me because I know that that's what I'm paying for.
You know what I mean?
I also mean as well. I understand that I've self, I don't need to do that.
Grids. Any money that I've ever put into Gacha no, from, from the beginning you,
would you ever say.
That you've fallen for something that is perhaps like, you know, maybe a little,
not predatory, but close to it, right? Maybe like, uh,
they keep offering you stuff, you know, there's deals constantly.
Look, I'm not going to lie and say that Gacha, isn't just gambling with WiFi's.
Cause it is okay. It's but like I've never seen, I've never,
I've never seen the appeal of casinos for, because,
because of the reason that I said where, you know, to me, casinos are scary.
Cause you, you pay for the chance to win more money. And that's, that's like,
that's, that's like that's to me, that's like a risk right there.
Cause that's literally just gambling.
But to me like Gacha is I'm paying for an experience I'm paying because
I actually want this thing that I'm putting money into. No one, I,
I actually want it. And it's,
it's different where people are going to meme this and say, Oh God,
God doesn't care about getting money. And that's not what I'm saying. Right.
I'm saying if I'm, if I'm going to get money,
there are plenty of other ways that I would want to get money. I,
as the last things,
the last gambling's the last way I would use to actually get money, I would.
Wanna work for that. But there's only one way to get wifi. I rarely give a.
About what meme do. Right. I'm not like that. But I guess, because we're,
we're in the position where we all have our own job, we were all old,
old people compared to the zoomers out there.
Okay. And probably you're the youngest one, but you're the
[inaudible] on Twitter sometimes. Right.
Hella normalized, right. Spending, you know, a hundred bucks on a few pools.
Right. Me and the boys going to pull a few WiFi's right, right.
And then the w w we're joking about it on Twitter, you know,
we we're going to be stream it, but it's not like, you know, someone goes.
A casino and his eye, or do a cheeky, like 10 pole on rubella hat. Right.
And then like, you know, everyone's beaming it.
The classic bet on red, meaning the ship, right.
To like 15 year olds who are.
Then wanting to do it. Right. I mean, like we have like a, like, I dunno,
it feels weird. Okay.
Well, what I would say is, okay,
like part of the reason why I've been spending more on like, gotcha.
Now is because 2020 has been boring as or 2020 was boring as. And I,
and I think to myself, what are, what would I be at?
What would I have spent that money on anyway, probably going out and getting.
Like how much do you spend on a, not on a night out? Like.
Yeah. It depends where [inaudible].
Let's say, let's say a standard sesh in London with the boys, right.
You can spend upwards of like hundred, 200 pounds on drinks.
What are you getting up to in London? Just pop a.
Champagne drink when a.
When one single cocktail in London is like a tenor. Like you,
you start off that, you start off like a Weatherspoon or something, you know,
that's, that's the cheap drinks,
but like get further or further along in the night,
people easily spend a hundred to 200 pounds on one night.
It's more out of that.
10 minutes of pulling that catcher then a whole night with your boys.
I mean, I would say that.
No, no, no, no, no. You're a politician right now. God, what is this? Come on.
I'm just, I'm just.
Saying like, like you, you, you are like, yo, I'm being attacked.
I need, I need her. I need to defend myself. I need to,
[inaudible].
You say, you say we've normalized the staff, but like, you are fine.
For example,
we're spending that much on a night out because that's what you choose.
You know, that's what you choose as the experience.
And that's what you choose is okay for the price. You know what I mean?
What you're saying is a night out with the boys is the equivalent to getting
your favorite life is there's tangible stuff. You're buying,
you're buying drinks there. That is stuff that has to be made that you're going,
you're transporting. This is all stuff that, you know, has a cost for a reason.
We can't show it's conflated because they know they can get away with it. Right.
They know they can charge this much for a pole. I mean,
it's the equivalent of like going out to a bar and buying a Tana drink and going
home and pouring yourself that same drink. Right? No, it's different.
Because like getting, uh, getting, uh, getting your favorite wine.
On a 40 Paul is, is the, is the pouring your drink at home? No, it's not.
What's the going out then? What's that the temple you pay for?
That's exactly what it is.
Oh my God. This is, this is so such low brain IQ. No dude. Okay. When you go to,
uh, uh, like let's say you go to a bar in London, right? You pay, I don't know,
nine pounds for a cocktail, you know, paying for the ingredients. Right.
You're paying for someone born to make it, you pay,
you're paying for the experience you're paying for the experience you're paying
for like, you know, the, the glass, the expertly prepared. Right.
You're paying for that. Yeah. Do you have nice cocktail glasses at home?
Oh no. I ain't going to buy them. They're like 30 Quip.
They have really nice ones. Right? Everything you get is tailored experience.
That's why the price goes. Is it a bit of a rip off? Yeah. Of,
but it's not like to the point where I feel like I'm being taken advantage of
Gacha games. I kind of do.
But that's just on, you.
Know, I feel like they, I,
I genuinely believe that like Gacha games to some extent are like, just take it,
getting away with as much as they can and take advantage of it.
Of course, they're getting close to this. I mean,
I'm not going to say that they're not getting away with it as much as I can.
I totally believe that there should be regulations around this stuff.
That's not the argument here. That's not the argument.
The fact that it took like multiple governments to get involved,
just to make them to show you the odds is like ridiculous.
Like how long were people getting over? Because they didn't know.
The percentage was 0.001.
Oh a long time. A long time.
I also didn't care. Yeah. But how is it ever acceptable? Like that,
that was okay. Like casino.
Right? Right. Like even just seeing them.
That's scummy. They'll let you know, like, I like this,
this just blows my mind and how people constantly defend them.
And they're like is I would re I would be more okay with,
if everyone just admitted, she's one big scam.
And we're all just in for it because.
It's not a scam though. It's not a scam. It's like one step away from a scam.
What's that one? What is a scam for you then? What is this genuinely?
Because to me a scam is like,
it means that you are getting what's, what's the word I'm looking for?
Like the users in the dark. We know exactly what we're getting ourselves into.
And that's why, to me, it is not a scam. It's like saying like, Oh,
on this banner, the 10 is a guaranteed six staff. When it's not a guarantee.
That's coming to stop any more like government regulation. Right.
Because if they were trying to get away with that.
That is a scam. If they're asleep, lying to the user base, then that's,
to me is a scam, which.
Sure many of them were at some point. Right. We didn't know. I mean,
come on.
And I think it's our Gacha games a little bit perjury. Yeah. They are.
And I feel like the best, the best weapon against that is just education. Right?
It's it's like, no, no, don't do drugs.
Have a wrinkly brain. That's all it is like, I mean, I'm even the up,
but if you want to, if you want me to talk about the, like the realities of it,
I will talk about the realities of it. And, and that's because I don't want,
I know exactly what I'm getting into with Gacha games.
And I know what my limits are.
I do think it's, it's gotten much better since they've won.
You get a guaranteed and you know, you get,
you get to see the rates that's much better. Yeah. That's increased it a lot.
Like I, I mean, I mean,
I mean the up that I'm like spending money on like literally a North
0.6%, but that's on me to make that decision.
But even, even if I wasn't, you know what I mean? I, I know it's on the person.
Not always. I think,
I think sometimes depending on how we were going in circles, kind of like,
depending on how the game is presented and made,
I think sometimes it can be on the game. Right.
And I hate how you can't even have this discussion of it being like, Oh,
you're just whining, bro. It's free to play any way. And it's like,
it's not that simple. I think it's never that simple. I mean, I,
I feel like if not opening the door to that conversation is irresponsible.
I mean.
For me, I feel like the conversation to me, it always ends up. If, if it,
if it doesn't feel like, you know, your type of game, like,
I don't feel like you were for Gacha games. And I, I genuinely believe that.
Cause I feel like someone with your personality, like a true gamer.
Just would never enjoy gotcha. Game.
No, I just, I hate that. I paying for part of a game. Yeah. I hate that.
And I'm.
Completely fine without gotcha. Games.
The reason I love Gacha games is because it suits my lifestyle perfectly.
It suits my mentality when it comes to playing games perfectly gotcha. Game.
I don't like, I'm not saying that Gacha shouldn't exist or anything like that.
I totally recognize that it has its place and it's got its value.
I just want like everything to be more transparent and there'll be the systems
in place to stop people going broke from them.
I don't think anyone should go broke from, like, I don't know, off nights.
So you kidding me? Like no, no one should be going broke from video games. Why,
why was that even an option?
I mean, it's, it shouldn't be an option and that's, that's what we agree.
Right, right. Yeah. And like, I just it's like,
we've totally like been made it totally memorable and okay. To be like, ah,
he's gone broke what an.
We haven't MeMed up people going, bro. Let's do man.
Who's meaning, don't go to the, I bet the sub bro,
every summer, if someone.
It's like, if someone's like, Oh,
I just spent hundred hundred dollars on a Gacha and I put with nothing.
That's that's, that's.
Basically like the same as what you did to.
Eugene being like you, you just spent,
you just spent a hundred pounds on a casino and you didn't.
And also there's nothing. There's nothing on Twitter.
That's not getting mean dog. Like you'll you can scroll on Twitter,
be like LOL his dad.
If someone has a legitimate problem. And someone's like, dude,
I've I've fully regrets, you know, spending this much on. Gotcha.
Then I'll be like, bro, I'm sorry. Just got to quit. You know what I mean?
That's this is, this is bad. This is bad. You shouldn't.
There's nothing.
[inaudible] there's nothing else we can say that we now position.
There's nothing else you can say.
Stop doing drugs, bro. Just stop. Why doing drugs, man? Like it's not that easy.
That's again. And the point that's no more, no more.
There should be regulations.
Bottom line should be Holman. Needs to make the gotcha.
A reality. One of the line,
there should be regulations with on how strictly are that's up for debate
between catch a players and a game.
Apparently per game of goals and gotcha. Game and goals.
Never-ending war.
I think there should be like a cool-down period. A hundred percent.
That's my that's my closing statements.